[Music]
you've conquered just about every medium
now you've moved on to app technology
yeah is that correct - that's not you're
working on an app yeah I'm for an app
called just saying and it allows you to
talk and post it to Twitter or Facebook
it's just a it's so simple it's free so
please download it and then you can chat
and do it sing a song it's um it's great
it's great fun now and you've you have a
contest that's associated with the APIs
oh yeah I thought we good idea to find
the next big comedian next week stand up
so when the winner would get to do a
live show here three minute
act on your show the great this show
that makes you cry when you have to go
on it yeah your big reward why should I
be the only one that suffers so they get
the chance to come on here and maybe
someone's watching from a real Channel
[Applause]
or just someone who runs a pub gig I
love you I must I don't want people to
think that I know I do that we love each
other dearly but you you have it's
actually a very nice idea people if they
win this contest
we'll give them a shot exactly they just
down the it up for free just go to the
website for details just saying app calm
and yeah it's the just original material
do a bit of you do a bit least and up
I mean you know we don't really want
louis c.k to enter but you know new
comedian anyone can enter Louise just
dying to get three minutes Louie